indignación y dolor el rostro de esta
joven refleja la tristeza de los
familiares de los muertos que dejó el
choque de trenes ocurrido el viernes al
suroeste de Calcuta su esposo de 27 años
trabajaba como plomero y regresaba a
casa en el tren pero la muerte lo
sorprendió la víctima también deja
huérfano a un bebé de tan solo dos meses
después de esta tragedia tan grande no
se ha sentido muy bien No ha comido ni
bebido nada ni siquiera agua es una gran
calamidad tanta pena y dolor ella se
casó hace apenas un año la empresa que
opera los trenes en esta región de India
está pagando una compensación
equivalente a 12 mil dólares por cada
víctima
mi hijo ha muerto qué será con
indemnización el dinero está aquí hoy se
gastará mañana pero mi hijo se ha ido es
como si me hubieran amputado la mano
derecha son 275 las familias que ahora
reclaman justicia y que se establezcan
responsabilidades según Las
investigaciones preliminares el tren de
pasajeros se salió de la vía principal e
ingresó a una zona de estacionamiento a
128 kilómetros por hora tras una falla
en la señalización el aparato chocó
contra un tren de carga estacionado